يتميز الحزب الجمهوريه الامريكي بتبني
سياسات متشدده في الشان الخارجي وتشمل
استعمال القوه العسكريه الامريكيه لحمايه
المصالح الحيويه ويحاول المرشحون الحاليون
اظهار انفسهم كقاده اقوياء
كرئيسه اولويته هي دعم الاقتصاد الامريكي
والجيوش الامريكيه سنحمل الازدهار
الامريكي وارضانا من التهديد الصيني
وسنواجه تدخل الصين في مجتمعنا وسنواجه
التلاعب وباقتصادنا وسنحمل الحزب الشيوعي
الصيني تبعات ذلك ونضعهم في موقف الدفاع
ينقسم الامريكيون بشده حول قضيه المهاجرين
وكانت الهجره غير الشرعيه عبر حدود
المكسيك في جوهر الحملات الانتخابيه كما
كانت في صلب السياسات الحكوميه بعدما
اثاراها
يؤكد المرشحون الجمهوريون على ضروره تنظيم
الهجره وبناء الحائط لكن حاكم فلوريدا
يقول ان ترامب لم يتمكن من انجاز المهمه
في العشرين من يناير من عام 2025 سنكون في
مهمه لوقف اجتياح الحدود الجنوبيه ومحاربه
شبكات المخدرات التي تسمم مواطنين وسنبني
حائط الحدود ونقيم سيادتنا على ارضنا
انتهينا من الوعود والشعارات الان وقت
العمل ولا اعذار وسننجز العمل
يتفق الجمهوريون على مبدا الحكومه الصغيره
وخفض الضرائب والسيطره على عجز الميزانيه
ويميلون عاده الى تبني مبدا تاييد الحياه
ويعارضون الاجهاض لكن سياساتهم المقترحه
من هذه القضيه تتباين في وضوحها
على كل مرشح جمهوري تاييد منع الاجهاض قبل
الاسبوع الخامس عشر كحد ادنى
كرئيس ساعمل على منع تمويل الاجهاض من
الضرائب
يفخر الرئيس الامريكي السابق والمرشح
الحالي دونالد ترامب بانه عين قضاه
محافظين وان الامر ادى الى قرار المحكمه
العليا بالغاء قرارها السابق باقرار
الاجهاض لكنه يرفض الافصاح عن المهله
الزمنيه
البعض يؤيد سته اسابيع واخرون ثلاثه
اسابيع او اسبوعين الرئيس ترامب سيقرر ما
يعتقد انه جيد وعادل للبلاد
قضيه الاجهاض على اهميه فائقه للناخبين
الجمهوريين بشكل عام فالجمهوريون حققوا
نتائج متواضعه في الانتخابات النصفيه
العام 2022
والناخبون صوتوا بكثافه للديمقراطيين
الذين لا يبدون اي اعتراض على الاجهاض حتى
في مراحل متاخره من الحمل في الغنم
العربيه واشنطن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات